population dans les airs à présent
direction le salon du bourget qui fête
cette année son centenaire et qui est
ouvert au public tous ce week end
au programme beaucoup de démonstrations
ont préparé avec une grande minutie les
pilotes évoluent dans un espace aérien
très encombré ce n'est pas simple pour
eux de trouver leur place patrick esther
et loïc le moigne accélère le bourget
c'est l'éclat des pilotes rotation et on
décolle pas au ciel les démonstrations
en vol
sanchez au top niveau mais derrière
cette apparente facilité se cache toute
une organisation réglée à la seconde et
au millimètre
la journée commence par l'immuable
briefing des pilotes le directeur des
voiles est intraitable avec la sécurité
et le règlement sa particularité du
bourget c'est que le volume est bien
spécifique duo d'agglomération qui ont
eu à déplorer
et pas question d'obtenir plus de 7
minutes de démonstration
même le pilote d'essais de l'airbus 380
jacques roset essayent en vain d'avoir
un peu de rab sept ans pour dégager la
plus touchée des rocheuses 30
we7 prend comme j'habite maintenant tu
et pourtant c'est vrai que l'a380 est un
cas un peu particuliers il est un peu
gros pour évacuer la piste rapidement
compliquer encore un peu le tout ces
avions volent dans des conditions
acrobatiques au beau milieu de l'espace
aérien parisien saturé par les milliers
de décollage et d'atterrissage du trafic
orly et roissy en tant que chef
militaire on n'a pas du tout l'habitude
d'être un briquet comme ça dans dans des
trafics danse surtout que les avions de
chasse généralement n'ont pas du tout
les mêmes
caractéristiques en termes de vitesse en
termes de maniabilité que les avions
civils
loin de simplifier la faire le salon de
l'aéronautique a décidé pour célébrer le
centenaire de sa création de faire voler
une trentaine de vieux coucous dézingue
qui eux échappent carrément ou radar
tel ce blériot 11 réalisé en toile et en
bois en 1909 il avait permis à louis
blériot de traverser la manche
des appareils un peu capricieux une
heure de vol 5h20 mécanique c'est le
ratio dit wen et c'est pour cela que
c'est beau de les voir voler avec aux
commandes des hommes un peu plus âgés
que les pilotes de chasse aux vieux
pilote
on n'a pas encore si vieux que ça mais
c'est clair nos avions d'un certain âge
celui l'allemande vibe est unique au
monde
dès demain le grand public pourra juger
sur pièce redonner le sourire